diane is awesome and she likes you and
you like her i can tell
a i don't recall inviting you in here
and b i did not like her
she's not my type her life is messy
messy is fun okay my whole life is a
giant mess and i love it i mean look at
my hair i have gum
in my hair let me explain something you
tweep when you're in a
situation you don't have time to think
so i thought to myself
don't think andy act so
you weren't thinking not at all
i cannot emphasize enough how little i
was thinking
were you scared no no i wasn't well i uh
i lived in the pit for the better part
of last year
and made some vermin friends
um you know what friends sound stupid
colleagues
uh they are bad at sharing
but they are good at tag can i cut in
line again
i feel right at home as a shoe shine i
have no idea what i'm doing but i know
i'm doing it really really well
margaret's pecan squares they're like
crack
i brought you one how are you so happy
working here i don't know man it's not
that bad a year ago i lived in a pit
now i got a job and a kick-ass wife
and my band is so good and are you gonna
eat that
pecan square
when life gives you lemons make
lemonade i read that once so i can't
eliminate it
but i like to think that it applies to
life
i don't want you to go back to london
just remember every time you look up at
the moon
i too will be looking at a moon not the
same moon obviously that's impossible
see you on stupid skype
hey captain uh status update my new
suspect
the dude who runs carpet emporium the
way i figure is criminals love to wrap
things up in rugs
plus he yelled at me when i tried to
unroll them all so andy while i
appreciate your
dedication to finding this criminal i
think you might want to take into
account what the policeman said i mean
gosh if i can't even investigate bad
guys
why become a cop at all what are you
doing
when i get bummed out to take my shirt
off because the bad feelings make me
feel sweaty
ah
[Music]
huh looks like andy's wearing him down
i'm gonna go finish him off
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard don't you just shut up for a
second
what's going on he's a jerk he is being
such a
jerk it's an awful thing to say to his
human being are you
crying no i'm not crying okay i'm
allergic to
jerks okay andy out fine i don't even
care it's stupid
i just got this super sweet ass rad
crotch rocket
i've always wanted one of these but due
to you know
never having a job i couldn't afford it
until now
got a really good deal on my lease
paying like 12
interest it's like one of the highest
you can get
hey so i've been trying like crazy to
get a hold of april if you see a
retailer i really need to talk to her
you got it all right thanks ron
nailed it whoa check out the new digs
this place is insane thanks for coming
guys i'm super swamped and i need your
help pass you came down here to pass on
helping me
yeah i wanted to see what your face
looked like when i said no
it was totally worth it andy are you
okay
oh i'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and i'm
always tired
also i can't sleep i'm overeating none
of my old hobbies interest me
ever since andy failed the police
academy exam his self-esteem
has hit rock bottom he's always sad and
sweaty
he's usually happy and sweaty look if
you're not gonna pay rent at least
clean up your dishes ah
is that all no also the bag of smells
was a fun experiment but it has to stop
come on no no we're finally starting to
get serious results andy dude
i love you but shape up or move out
what's going on the guitarist from my
band is driving me crazy he's such a
control freak
uh that's not a working fireplace andy
stop writing phone messages on the wall
andy dude seriously i love you but stop
digging that weird hole in the backyard
is mouse rack gonna break up well we're
not moss right anymore we change it to
tackle shaft
oh i should just get my own place you
should
i'll help you you could help me yeah
that'd be fun
april you're like an angel with no wings
so like a person you have two broken
bones in your right arm and four in your
hand
that's the side that hurts how soon
until he's better
we'll set the fractures i'd like to keep
him overnight for observation
uh is there any chance you can fix me in
the next 10 minutes
sure i'll just advance medical science
30 years
great can mouse rat play without you
they tried once they're called
rat and mouse and they're awful but you
have got to find somebody
there's an old saying in show business
the show must go wrong
everything always goes wrong and you
just have to deal with it
ah hey uh babe it's me will you come
down here please and keep me company i'm
so bored i need you
if i come down there can i at least
break something of course babe anything
you know that
chris gave me this great job as a
weekend security guard at city hall only
one problem
it's a terrible job i did everything i
was supposed to do and i walked around
the building four times only 20 minutes
has gone by
i thought maybe 10 minutes had gone by
since i started talking it's only been
15 seconds
oh
oh babe thank god you're here i got so
bored i started thinking about existence
do i matter do any of us is there a
master plan in the works a grand design
just dumb stuff like that
yeah who cares ah i thought being a
security guard would be exciting
nope
[Music]
oh well that beeping was sure annoying
but this is even more annoying
i'll handle this the monitor is not a
toy andy
anything is a toy if you play with it
chalk that up to your concussion
well the good news is your cat scan's
clear
oh andy i'm really happy you're okay
leslie was worried too we should have
checked before to see if you were
home oh no i told you i moved out of the
pit i just had to go back cause i forgot
my headphones and i laid down on this
really comfy tarp
i saw an old cereal box i hadn't read
before so i must have drifted off
next thing you know
dirt that's good jeff one second
and back down there you go oh
that is perfect it's like i'm lying in a
cloud
this is awesome and in andy just like
old times
the pit works in mysterious ways
come on andy come on you can do it go go
go go go go go go go go
yes oh my god that's so hot it was
horrible
oh i'm going to die i'm so tired
everything hurts running is impossible
what are you doing tom now is not the
time for criticism
how did he do and he finished his
two-mile run in 29 minutes and 43
seconds
no i'm never gonna be a cop
i'm gonna have to be a robber oh come on
the receptionist says she'll fit you in
as soon as there's an opening
if you're all right i'm going to head
back to the park
liquid do you know what my social
security number is
or if i'm allergic to anything i don't
like corn
should i put that down or will that be
confusing because i do like
candy corn oh ron
what a mess
here let me help you all i wanted was
two hours where i got to forget that i
was
a parent huh look i found all three
differences
those are two completely different
pictures
who the hell is forp i don't know i
couldn't really hear him
it sounded like his name was for get his
number no
good girl ron swanson
april ludgate hey i'm just gonna pop
over to grain and simple to get the very
best ingredients for my burger do you
want to come
what is grain and simple it's a health
food store pawnee doesn't have a health
food store
no but snurling does and it's only a 40
minute drive
what are you doing andy i'm getting
healthier snacks for the shoeshine stand
chris is a food genius
did you know that the food you eat
becomes energy yeah
boom that's spaghetti nachos
it's a cookie that's my husband
and i get why you don't want anyone to
know about duke silver and you don't
have to worry
your secret is safe with me to even it
out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's
not necessary i once forgot to brush my
teeth for five weeks
i didn't actually sell my last car i
just forgot where i parked it i don't
know who al gore is and at this point
i'm too afraid to ask
when they say two percent milk i don't
know what the other 98
is when i was a baby my head was so big
scientists did experiments on me
i once threw beer and swan and then it
attacked my niece rebecca
you